i have hundreds of minecraft players
here and we're going to attempt the
highest jump ever here's how it works we
have seven extremely challenging free
falls the players are gonna drop down
like this and if they do that
they'll teleport them to obstacle course
number two and whoever completes the
final free fall jump first
wins 10 000 that's me carl
yes chandler yes go to a different
discord call you guys are competing
server drop those barriers begin the
challenge everyone
free fall oh my gosh look at them all
falling
this freaking pull man i'm gonna attempt
it chris i'm gonna attempt to do it go
for it oh oh
oh oh oh boom and then you get
teleported over here
to course number two as you can see
quite a few people have already beaten
the first course
easy easy oh my oh i'm insane yeah i'm
gonna tp to carl
chris promise me this video you will not
kill carl i promise
you i will not but i will watch him die
we have a few stragglers left on the
first course but whatever screw them
we're going to move on without them
open the gates
server drop the second gate oh my gosh
i could just picture the screaming chant
as they all jump in right now
oh let's go let's go open the third gate
baby if you die on the second course you
don't come back to the second course
here
you go back to the first course and you
have to beat that to come back here to
redo it
you gotta go around the loop oh my
lantern
come on i don't understand that's my
thing i'm just watching all these kids
slap the concrete i'm gonna attempt it
all right so
you fall here you fall here wait all
right so i would have died if i wasn't
in creative they're all getting stuck up
there look
they're not even making it down here
dude there's a decent amount of people
already at three oh
chandler's over here on the third one
what do you think chandler's talking
about right now he's probably talking
about how good he is and how bad carl is
carl if you don't win you get kicked
wait what you have three minutes
to get where to the third yes
oh no trumpets engraving oh he just got
to the second one and died yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
before we open the third gate i just
want to show you how beautiful it is
look at these planets so if you're a
player you're going to walk to this edge
and you're going to jump and you're
going to fly past whatever planet that
is and that planet
and that planet and boom you're going to
hit this this is kind of like what i do
every day
driving your tesla yeah my tesla that i
have but what about your old tesla that
you lost in this clip
oh wait no way and it comes with all his
clothes
all right server open the third gate go
let's go i'm gonna let people jump
oh oh i hit the corner ah
no no let's go
why am i messed up why am i all messed
up they're dropping into the deep abyss
of space dude
oh from this angle right here this looks
really cool
everyone's dying no one's making it go
go to station number four see how many
are getting through
no one's making it oh one person made it
what the heck
i gotta go back to the beginning i'm
gonna pour water and make them all fall
in get pushed in
oh no no wait wait and they're using my
water against me
they're riding the water down the water
stops here
wait no it got bigger no way we have to
contain it
they're falling in a crash i'm david
dress
it's going in and you just have to check
it's going on how is there a bunch of
water down here how's there a bunch of
water down here who did this
yay i'm actually doing very good yeah
because you rode the water down you
cheater
what am i thought it was there chris
this person who cheated even has beast
merch on my own kind
and now that we dealt with those
cheaters it is time for course number
four uh-oh
oh this is beautiful but hard carl i'm
gonna just tell you this now there's no
way you beat this carl you're not making
it through this
i can barely beat the first one i'll
beat it first try i'll beat your first
try
all right server open the gates
a lot of people are hitting this right
here and the people that survived
trailer um
put you back at the start for bud
oh i was so close to it and like we said
before if you die on a course you go
back to the beginning all right so
chandler's on floor number one
carl's on floor number two let's go
ahead and open up the fifth floor let's
get on
let's get further ahead open the gate
oh there's a decent amount of people
that made it i guess the other people
who didn't just aren't good
open the gates oh there's so many people
are you close to this one
oh he made it first try all right
chandler are you gonna catch up to
everyone let's see
all right chandler dropped he dropped oh
oh god all right chandler beat it let's
go
jimmy this guy sir cookie noob made the
hardest drop ever
in one try all right chandler just
dropped let's see does chandler make it
does he make it oh girl died on level
one what a nerd stop leave me alone
they keep pushing me oh
my god so far only five people have made
it to level six
out of a hundred oh six people now hey
contestants can you hear me i just
wanted to remind you that ten thousand
dollars is on the line
i have no idea what you're saying i'm
gonna leave dude
level six has like hardly anyone added
where are you guys there's a level six
there's a level seven
can someone tell me where the water is
on level five so i can jump oh there he
goes
there he goes i didn't see that piece of
gray
oh that tree at the bottom
i'm gonna cry oh my gosh planet trees
i'm taking this shirt off as you can see
a lot of people are struggling with
level three
there's a few people on level four a few
more people on level five and these are
the people waiting for us to open level
six so
i think we should reward the people
who've made it this far and go ahead and
open it up
hike if these people die on this part of
the course they have to go all the way
to the beginning
jimmy this is evil oh my gosh so many of
them are dying they're gonna have to
restart
chris have anyone scored oh one guy
there's three guys here at seven
three people have made it this forest is
insane
no no what if this is the guy who made
this map
yeah what if he's one of our builders
dude there's people already on level
seven they're just having a good time
over here
i think i think carl's cheating i think
he is too cause i've been helping him
i'm sorry you told me not to kill him so
the opposite of kill is hell bro
you gave me no choice no cheetsy
deetsies i've said from day one no
cheats
[Music]
it wasn't me we have strict no cheating
rules in mr b's challenges
you can take my pride you can even take
my dignity but the second
you take my right to be in the server
that's when you take it too
far this is the seventh and final drop
chris
let's see how hard it is all right all
right hold up
all right i would have died there and i
would have died
oh if i wasn't in creative mode i would
have died three times
yeah this is hard the drop so far it
literally takes me five years to climb
back up my beard is growing border
welcome to the discord call can you hear
me oh yeah so border you were the first
person to complete the first six levels
congratulations well so here's the deal
this is the seventh and final level and
since you were the first to get to this
level
we wanted to let you drop first so when
you drop
if you land in that water you win ten
thousand dollars in cash
no pressure he went from looking at me
to looking through the glass trying to
strategize all right
border make the ten thousand dollar drop
oh oh he dropped he dropped he dropped
where
where oh oh oh oh oh
you were so close it was so close dang
border that was close i watched that
whole thing
sink graves saltine you two are the
second and third people to reach forward
number seven which means you guys get
the honors
of dropping second and third also if
saltine lands five seconds before you
sink he wins the ten grand just so
you're aware
nothing tell me when you're ready and
i'll go why would you go at the same
time jump before him whoever lands first
wins
oh he wins oh he win he wins he win
oh my gosh he was half a block away
baby milks and jakes you guys are the
fourth and fifth person to get to the
seventh level
so we're gonna give you guys an
exclusive jump before everyone else
you're the last exclusive jump you know
how much baby milk you can get with that
oh oh all right don't go the lava no
all right baby milk don't do that oh he
dropped
oh he's going he's going high speed
not even close all right server open the
seventh
and final round ten thousand dollars is
on the line
all right let's do this everyone is
dropping again the border is not dropped
yeah there he goes
he's getting ready making it close i see
lots falling are they falling close
everyone just jumped from floor number
seven and not a single one of them
scored the ten grand
is still waiting to be claimed oh border
is here and it's vin
okay we got three people on floor number
seven all right border jordan
border dropped border drop oh i can't
even keep up with him he's so good did
he hit it did he hit it
he did not oh i'm big sad
a few people are about to drop this is
hard
oh george ii church who did it jertsu
did
also won this challenge jutsu zero zero
five pick the ten thousand dollar block
jersey you have won twenty thousand
dollars
in two months is this like your new
full-time career or maybe i'm not gonna
work anymore
congratulations on winning another ten
thousand dollars i don't know how jared
zu keeps winning
thank you so much hit that subscribe
button goodbye